christmas is approaching you are
scrambling to find a last-minute gift we
just gave you the definitive ranking of
gifts for your woke friends and family
members i did forget one by the way in
that collection which is my book reasons
to vote for democrats a comprehensive
guide that's a blank magnum opus but now
what about the conservatives in your
life well we have got
the definitive tier ranking
of conservative gifts this christmas
season for the most hardcore
conservatives all the way down to the
most basic normies just kind of dipping
their toe in we've got the s tier then a
b and c at the top at the s tier those
are the kinds of right wingers who are
on a first name basis with the horn guy
okay they are really hardcore
right below that you've got the a tier
these are your people who they're
they're pretty serious about their
conservatism they for instance crash
school board meetings on the weekends
just for fun you've got the b tier these
are the people who if they have been at
a sporting event or concert recently
they will chant let's go brandon you
know it's a lot of people but there are
a lot of people in that group let's go
and then at the lowest level tier the
most basic kind of conservative that
would be the people who just don't hate
their dads left-wing politics basically
amounts to screw you dad so these would
be the people who just have a halfway
decent relationship with their father
now think about that
let's get into the gift buying guide
first one is the unvaxed necklace okay
so this is
this is going to be higher than just
having a good relationship with your dad
i mean there are plenty of conservatives
who are into the vaccine frankly some of
them are even into
certain kinds of mandates or maybe
they're okay with the employer mandate
so it's going to be a little higher than
that
are you crashing school board meetings
no no you're not quite there you're
willing to be pretty public about your
views but i'm not sure that you're
seeking out actual political kind of
public fora you're just you're open
about it that would be a b-tier gift
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guy this is very important
it's a very important gift
not only is it just c tier meaning it's
for everybody you know it is for anyone
even slightly on the conservative side
of the aisle but i would go further than
that this is really for the democrats
too this is for the libs you know this
is
there's no better gift that you could
give than the gift of knowledge this
christmas so that would be that's for
everyone see tier next gift the freedom
phone this is an uncensored phone i've
heard about this i don't know a ton
about the freedom phone i'm just a
caveman your world frightens and
confuses me so here yeah you've got a
good relationship with your dad you
definitely chant let's go brandon i mean
if you're willing to
change the way that you communicate
everywhere then you're definitely saying
let's go brandon you're probably
crashing school board meetings i think
this would be an a tier gift it's just
below being buddies with the horn dude
i identify as non-bidenery
that's
so boomer that's such a boomer mug which
i say in great love some of my best
friends are boomers
but that is that's pretty
pretty low level right whenever you're
talking just about candidates you know
just like trump bad or biden bad way and
you're not getting to the kind of deeper
more systemic problems you're probably
more at the normie level of things so
this would be a c tier gift you don't
hate your dad but you haven't gone much
deeper than that
let's go brandon's soy candle
[Music]
says smells like fake news is full of
fruitcakes
i want that gift that's a great gift so
yeah you got a good relationship with
your dad obviously you're chanting let's
go brandon in sporting events
you're going to school awards i think if
you
are you no maybe no i'm going to pull
that back this is a b level
this casts a pretty wide net i think and
i want it so if you want to get me a
christmas gift that's what i want i want
that candle
any use of fruitcake i think is is good
and should be encouraged a new wing to
the playhouse made entirely of
fruitcakes just a proud dad that didn't
raise liberals is this this is the
boomer shopping we're this we're on qvc
right now i think is what we're selling
uh-oh that that would be c tier
so you don't have a problem with your
dad or with your kids obviously because
you didn't you didn't raise liberals and
presumably you would be getting this for
your dad so you're getting the gift you
like him that's ctr i mean i like it if
if my little bundle of joy got me this
for christmas i would be i would be very
happy
joe biden toilet paper is
so cheap
such a cheap joke but it's still kind of
funny you know it's this is why in the
entire history of comedy going back to
antiquity
fart jokes have always been funny and no
one really wants to admit that they are
but they are in every age no matter how
sophisticated this is all them this is
all their fart fault
go after them yes i did say this is all
their fault forget about that they are
there's just something funny and there
is something funny about
someone you don't like having their face
on toilet paper uh again this is sea
tier this is you don't need to be very
far
down the rabbit hole to appreciate this
all faster than dialing 911. and this is
pretty i like this so you got it's all
these different rounds of ammo
okay so you got to be a little more in
it i think i think you've got to be a
little more in it than just your basic
level conservative
there are plenty of conservatives people
center right who don't like a lot of
these weapons like there's a 556-223
around there a lot of people in the
center right they don't really like the
ar-15 you know
so i would say this would be beetier
this is where you you have chanted let's
go brandon
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady in
scotland just like me
your humble host lord michael knowles
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land you could even get
a couple pack for you and your spouse or
loved one of unspecified distinction you
will be able to have land right next to
one another at one square foot and you
will both get to be called lord and lady
you can get this on your credit card on
your plane tickets you can even put it
on your dating profiles
establish titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com knowles use promo
code knowles to save an extra 10
today
all right next
make america great again hat okay so
this
this is great i actually was decorating
my christmas tree recently and i found i
actually have the gold leaf red magga
hat ornament that you order from
trump.com a few years ago my wife got it
for me for christmas i love it we have
been on every single mailing list ever
since we got it but it's really great i
was one of the first people to buy a
maga hat i actually ordered a maga hat
back when it was white right when it
came out but the maga hat is not just
for anyone i mean there were there were
a lot of never trumpers and even not
just the whiny never trumpers but there
were people who had you know legitimate
fears about trump at least the first
time around they thought he might be
kind of a lib or whatever so
if you're going to actually wear the
maga hat in public which basically puts
a target on your back for every crazy
lib who wants to do you harm
you're actually probably crashing school
board meetings on the weekend i think
this is going to be an a tier not
because it's so crazy to support trump
obviously not you know you guy was
elected president at least one time
but
you're putting a target on your back so
you really have to have some hoots but
you got to have some spinal fortitude to
do it and i put positive energy into the
hat
the let's go brandon t-shirt i think i
don't i have some of that gear yeah i do
all right so we got everyone has let's
go brandon gear now you know
i don't even remember who gave me this
or why this brim is flat like i'm a
rapper
[Music]
that would be beatier wouldn't it that's
that one seems pretty obvious it's
pretty pretty basic stuff
a gun
that's uh
pretty blunt it's a blunt blunt
instrument a blunt force instrument so
this would be a little little higher
than
a person who doesn't hate their dad you
know this would be higher than the
normies i guess there's the kind of lib
version of giving guns which is like
gang bangers in the streets of chicago
or something but if we're talking about
just like good law-abiding citizens
exercising their second amendment rights
this is b tier if you have chanted let's
go brandon at a sporting event and you
received a gun for christmas you
wouldn't be freaked out by that right
you wouldn't whereas if you were just a
kind of normie level like you tune into
some conservative channels sometimes
where you might be freaked out
especially if you grew up on the coasts
man my friends where i grew up in new
york i lived in los angeles if you even
told them that you had a firearm they
would probably report you to the fbi
so yeah i would say this is this is be
tier
democratic ugly christmas sweater this
is my ugly christmas letter and it's
just a bunch of democrats
oh man the i guess christmas gifts they
they do tend to have a very
kind of like boomery quality to them and
i really don't
i don't mean this to mock boomers i just
mean like that's it's kind of been
around a long time you know the jokes
are tried and true they're nothing
really shocking or edgy just because you
know you're giving gifts to so many
people it's you wanted to play it a
little bit safer so this is safe this is
this is c tier
don't
okay so that's probably a little bit
higher than just because it's not just
like biden's dumb like a village is
missing as idiot or what you know the
ones they use for every presidential
administration this is a little more in
it you need to know that biden has this
creepy habit of sniffing people's hair
and specifically the hair of children
widen is sucking the blood of children
you need to know what a gadsden flag is
the early american flag that has been
sort of appropriated by libertarians and
constitutionalists
um you don't need to go to school board
meetings to make a joke about joe biden
sniffing people i'm going to say it's
b-tier
donald trump makeup bag
so this is a little more interesting to
me because it's not just some cheap
schlocky joke it actually looks like a
pretty nice makeup bag that's definitely
leather there were pearls hanging out of
it so this is
pretty expensive it's not just a novelty
gift this probably costs some money what
could it cost ten dollars
so it's higher than c
or b
you're definitely crashing school board
meetings in your spare time this is a
tier stuff
nancy
nancy pelosi's lectern so
this one i think you literally
need to be on a first name basis with
the horn guy here because you would have
been with the horn guy to acquire the
lectern
[Music]
or if you bought it on the second hand
market i don't know it's not like you
can find it on ebay right so you're
gonna have to know somebody i would say
nancy pelosi's lectern is very much an
s-tier gift and i do not support
or condone
theft
or the black market and stolen goods
but if someone if someone anyone out
there got me nancy pelosi's lectern
for christmas
we can talk okay that's all i'm saying
yeah look like someone who would be
interested in nancy pelosi's lectern all
right last one speechless controlling
words controlling minds baby talk about
a self-serving video
two of my books
on this list
speechless
you know actually i was going to say
speechless is for everyone you should
buy this for everybody and i think you
should and i think everyone would
benefit from it because the argument i
make in it is not just a kind of
polemical partisan attack but actually
spends probably more time attacking dumb
squishy right wingers than it even does
attacking the left and it's mostly just
a history of language and political
correctness but
i do think you
in order to really appreciate the
arguments you have to have been paying
attention to politics i'm not saying you
need to be some phd
who's read all the great philosophical
works or anything but but you have to be
aware that something has gone wrong
you have to be aware that whatever we've
been doing for the past 20 years hasn't
really been working all that well and
we've basically lost the entire culture
so i would say this is this is sea tier
this is the most general open to
conservatives if you have like basically
a good relationship with your dad if
you're not just like angry all the time
and pulling your hair out and screaming
if you recognize
that the progressive left is has caused
some problems then i think you'll love
that book speechless controlling words
controlling minds number one national
bestseller thanks to you not thanks to
the new york times which totally snubbed
it even though i outsold their number
one book by 40 that's fine no big deal i
hope you have a great uh great christmas
season shopping for all your wonderful
conservative friends
and family members we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]